[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER EISGRUBER:
Higher education
today is probably more important
than it has been at any time
in the past.
But at the same
time, universities
are facing a wide
range of challenges
and having to satisfy diverse
group of constituencies.
What is online
education going to mean
for colleges and universities?
How are colleges
and universities
going to deal with budget
pressures around the world?
And these issues are
arising at a time
when universities
are simultaneously
facing different
pressures but interacting
around the world more than
they ever have before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GIDEON ROSEN: One of the
great opportunities presented
by the forum is not
so much to assess
the state of online courses
and higher education,
but to get a clearer view
of what sorts of questions
we want to ask.
The most interesting thing
about the online revolution
in education-- if that's
what it's going to be--
is that we don't know
what kind of threat
or what kind of
opportunity it presents.
CECILIA ROUSE: It can
certainly help increase access.
That we understand.
Can we maintain quality
at the same time,
I think is an open question.
And I think whether
it really helps
to slow the increases in cost,
is an open question as well.
I think Princeton
can certainly play
a very important role
in that endeavor.
GIDEON ROSEN: It is
now possible for us
to see not only how we teach,
but how our colleagues teach.
And how our colleagues in other
very different universities
in the United States teach, how
our colleagues around the world
teach.
And for them to see
how we do what we do.
CECILIA ROUSE: This issue of
how do we maintain and possibly
improve access while
maintaining and improving
quality and keeping
it affordable
is the challenge for higher
education of our time.
The commitment to higher
education-- the fact that
when an individual attends a
post-secondary institution--
not only is the benefit
to that individual,
but all of us in society
benefit from having
more highly educated
individuals and workers.
And therefore, we need
to also be subsidizing
and to help our students go
through those institutions.
CHRISTOPHER EISGRUBER: I'm
very grateful to William Fung
for enabling Princeton to host
the Fung Global Forum this year
and annually.
Each year, the forum
addresses an issue
of major significance-- not
only to academics, but also
to policy makers in the world.
I think this year's
event in Paris
will be a terrific
opportunity to bring together
a wide variety of people on an
issue of critical importance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]